women's history month does not enjoy
exactly the same status as pride month
or Black History Month of the three
sacred celebrations women's History
Month which began this week is certainly
the lowest on the totem pole still it is
a it's an important uh and holy time on
the leftist liturgical calendar
especially because it presents yet
another opportunity to celebrate LGBT
people to be specific women's history
month is a time to celebrate men gay men
who masquerade as women that's certainly
um how the Hershey's Corporation sees it
anyway
that's why this week as you've probably
heard the candy company unveiled its he
for she Campaign which is meant to quote
shine a light on the women and girls who
Inspire us every day and they selected
five women to be a part of this so to be
faces of this initiative and each of the
women will even have their likenesses
adorned Hershey's chocolate bar
wrappings for the for the duration of
the month
but the interesting thing about one of
these women is that uh he is not a woman
at all but rather a man pretending to be
a woman trans activist Faye Johnstone
announced his inclusion in the campaign
this week with this video
my name is Faye Johnstone I'm the
executive director of wisdom to action
we can create a world where everyone is
able to live in public space as their
honest and authentic selves see the
woman changing how we see the future at
Hershey's Canada
now it's already as absurd and as
insulting as it can possibly get for a
major corporate brand to make this man
who by the way also looks and sounds
like a man
um a representative of women but
a glance at Johnstone's history and at
his social media posts tells an even
darker story
in fact Hershey has inadvertently
provided us with I think a very
revealing illustration of how trans
activists are made
and what they do with the privilege that
their self-identity affords them this is
not the company's intention to give us
this lesson we can assume that it wasn't
but they have given us this instructive
case study in any case
so it's worth I think investigating to
see what we can learn from it so
follow with me briefly as we go through
the story of Faye Johnstone
and we go all the way back to a few
years ago to 2014 and 2015. back then
Faye Johnstone then known as Zach
was posting on Instagram with hashtags
like gay boy and proud in fact he
even posted a public acknowledgment of
because at the time he identified as a
gay man and around that same time he
posted a public acknowledgment of an
apology for his quote CIS privilege
begging forgiveness for taking up space
as a queer male in that 2015 post this
is what he wrote this was Zach he says I
want to acknowledge my own CIS privilege
and say that across the board white
queer men like myself take up space that
marginalizes the most oppressed and
diverse members of our community
now it's quite a strange thing to see
yourself as merely taking up space but
this is what left us identity politics
entails if you're a white male
but then an interesting thing happened
after taking some women's history
classes and reading some feminist
literature and confronting his CIS
privilege some more all this is
documented on his Instagram Instagram
page Zach eventually decided that uh
well it turns out he's not CIS at all he
was no longer taking up space nor did he
owe any apologies over the next few
years he would identify as Femme and
quote non-binary and then land
eventually on trans it didn't take him
very long after discovering his non-cis
identity to monetize it
he put up another Instagram post in uh I
think it's 2017 advertising himself as a
professional queer quote unquote and
seeking honorariums and paid gigs
magically John Stone was now in a
position to not only make money off of
this identity but to lecture the CIS
allies that he was just identifying
himself with like five seconds ago in
2017 he posted this
quote allyship means means taking
cisgender heterosexual spaces and making
them queer and trans-inclusive it means
not expecting trans and non-binary
people to have to educate everyone
around them every day and in every new
space it means being there and being
consistent
so many allies talk a big game but we
need you to do more than talk
this is a man who had once not long
before felt the need to apologize for
taking up space now he was blaming
others for taking up space that belonged
to him
how quickly can a white male go from
apologizing for his privilege to
scolding other people for theirs all you
have to do is put on a dress it's that
simple
and these days you don't even do that
much
John Stone wants the oppressor
was now once the oppressor was now
apparently the oppressed
and now it makes his living as a
professional activist he also takes full
advantage of the victim privilege that
he has claimed for himself as he
advocates for many horrific things
including putting Women In Harm's Way
just a few days ago John Stone
reprimanded someone for saying that male
rapists who identify as trans shouldn't
be housed in women's prisons he claimed
that trans identifying male sex
offenders must be placed in women's
prisons in the name of quote trans
liberation
the the separation of male and female
prisoners is not a solution he said
it Bears repeating here and emphasizing
a man who wants to lock women prisoners
into cages with male sex offenders and
violent rapists
is the person who her she chose to be a
representative of women for women's
History Month
it gets worse John Stone has also
explicitly advocated for vilifying quote
unquote his words women who disagree
with gender ideology he said that such
women turfs as he calls them should be
shouted down until they quote don't dare
to speak their views publicly
and this is not new or unique rhetoric
coming from him back in 2017 he was
calling for quote militant queers to
rise up against his political enemies
nowadays John Stone advocates for
mandatory trans affirming indoctrination
of children in public school a few
months ago he called for our school
boards to establish quote Best Practices
to ensure all students learn about
accepting trans people
and as for parents who might object he
believes that as he stated that parents
don't have absolute rights over their
own children
now none of these Revelations are
shocking they don't even really count as
Revelations
I mean of course this male trans
activist hates women and doesn't care if
they're put In Harm's Way of course
all male trans activists hate women
because they resent and despise the
people who authentically belong to an
identity group that they covet but will
never really be a part of it's that
simple
and also they're all narcissists I mean
every single one
it's why they're transactus
they care about nobody and nothing
except their own affirmation whatever
sacrifices must be made to make them
feel affirmed are worth it
and if that means that women have to get
raped in prison
as far as they're concerned they're fine
with it they're more than fine with it
mean they hate women after all remember
the uh the militant rhetoric expressly
calling for the vilification of their
opponents wishing to uh make their you
know women too afraid and intimidated to
even speak in public
this is also no surprise it is how trans
activists and LGBT activists have
leftist activists in general have always
operated
you know while people on the right
complain that my rhetoric is too mean
Too abrasive the other side has proudly
and explicitly set out to demonize
anyone who disagrees with him and
they'll even tell you that's what
they're doing
they're not having any conversation
about tone
okay there's no tone policing going on
on that side they all agree
whatever tone is necessary to harass and
terrorize the enemy is the right tone as
far as they're concerned
this is how they fight this war while
many on our side are still trying to you
know play patty cake with these people
it's also not a surprise
though very important to note
how Johnstone settled on his woman
identity in the first place I mean you
could track a similar progression for
nearly every young trans activist in the
country today especially since they've
all Left Behind extensive documentation
they've all left behind a paper trail on
social media so we can see how John
Stone came to understand
that he was the villain according to his
own ideology
as a cisgender quote-unquote white male
his role was to apologize and to step to
the side
he was a warm body taking up space
but nobody wants to see themselves that
way nobody wants to be that so over time
he came to see that there's a way around
this
he doesn't have to resign himself to his
position in in the caste system
all he had to do was declare himself
something other than male and a simple
declaration is all it takes
and suddenly he finds himself situated
at the top of the pyramid
moments before he was at the bottom
pyramid is flipped on its head it's as
simple as that
it's really no wonder that trans and
non-binary identification have risen so
sharply there's lots of social capital
and also Financial Capital to be gained
from that identity and it only takes a
snap of the fingers to obtain it
now as for uh Hershey's
it's likely that the company didn't know
many of these background details when
they appointed Faye Johnstone their
spokesman or a spokeswoman as they would
claim
they uh you know that that certainly
isn't meant to be an excuse for the
company
not at all
the point is that they wouldn't have
done any background research or looked
into this guy at all all they needed to
know is that he's trans
and that automatically makes them above
reproach
and any attempt to investigate his
background or vet him or look into his
past statements would be an affront
against him
so I can guarantee you that they
specifically decided not to do that
this is what the law of Dei dictates
and Hershey's like most other
corporations is simply following that
law
and now they should suffer the
consequences for it
I mean we have to start really
penalizing these corporations for their
unthinking allegiance to this perverse
Twisted ideology nobody needs Hershey's
right we we could all go
the rest of our lives and never touch
another one of their products and and it
would it would require nothing of us it
would require no sacrifice at all
like it would not affect all the people
who are disgusted by what Hershey's has
done here
if all of us just said okay well I'm
never eating anything that Hershey makes
ever again
um it it would be a major win in in the
culture
and also it would require it would not
affect our lifestyles at all we could
easily do it
and so that's what we need to do one
great way to make them pay for their
wokeness is to turn to the Alternatives
but what are the Alternatives well funny
you should ask that here's the report
from the daily wire
Hershey's chose the first day of women's
History Month to insult all women and
rational Men by introducing a gender
dysphoric man who claims to be female is
one of the faces of its commemorative
she bar it even rolled out a social
media ad with Faye Johnstone gushing
about how she and other women are
changing how we see the future it was
too much for the daily wire co-founder
Jeremy boring who has built a reputation
for taking on woke companies and
offering alternatives to their consulted
customers already a razor magnate razor
and soon to be producer of wholesome
children's content boring is now a
chocolatier
is that what we call people to make
chocolate I guess so after after a
delusion Twitter users appeal to him to
offer another choice
fine Borg tweeted early Friday I'll do
it introducing Jeremy's chocolate yes
it's real we have two kinds he him and
she her one of them has nuts if you need
me to tell you which one keep buying
Hershey's
so
that's the news this is a this is a real
thing that now exists that uh now there
is Jeremy's chocolates and you can go to
ihatehersheys.com and you can find the
website and you can find the the options
for the chocolate bar right now looks
like there are just the two options but
uh if we learned anything from Jeremy's
razors we know that there will be many
more options still to come now
uh you know it's a it's a meme now
right on on social media that every time
a company goes woke everyone always says
oh I guess the daily wire is going to
make their own version
uh but it's not just a meme it's real
life we we are bringing the memes to
life here at the daily wire and I'm very
proud of that and it's a great thing for
two reasons okay one is like the obvious
one that uh that the serious one that it
is important to build alternatives
um
and
you know it
makes it even easier on the consumer end
to
move away from these well companies if
those Alternatives exist
which is why we're building them
and it it should be really easy because
as I said even without the alternative
there's no reason like nobody needs
Hershey's
and so if they if we don't need you we
don't need you and if you're going to
come in and spit in our faces
then
I mean how much would we have to
how much
you know
disrespect what we have to have for
ourselves to continue buying this
product that we don't need and could
easily go without from a company that is
directly spitting in our faces
but it becomes all the easier when there
are these Alternatives that we have now
uh and now we have Jeremy's chocolates
but also number two the the second thing
is that it's it's it is great trolling
and I do think that there is a it
there's a virtue in in trolling I've
talked about this recently that
you know we can engage the left we can
fight back and you know
on many different levels there's
legislation there's you know of course
you have to make the arguments you have
to do all these things but there is a
real virtue of trolling too and of
mockery
because these people are
and what they represent is
uh it's it's what they what you know
their ideology is poisonous and it's
destructive but it's also completely
ludicrous
and we can't lose sight of that
that's part of the trolling is to point
that out that's part of the mockery is
to point that out
and that's why there's a real value in
it
[Music]
[Applause]